i got back together with an ex and i was
[ __ ] her and i was like you missed
this dick and she goes i guess
[Music]
all right i'm chris o'connor uh this is
nate marshall hey marshall yeah sorry i
said that before it's fine it's fine
i like introductions
would you rather prematurely come in
your pants before sex or start crying
mid sex uh crying
pre-cum
i'd cry
what i just make something up this [ __ ]
is so pretty
stop crying you know she ate the same
angle but with the pre-cut
i was gonna be like you're so hard
i shouldn't be seen crying
because you could pre-cum and then you
could get hard again and [ __ ] right but
if you're crying mid-sex it's got it's
over i want to guarantee [ __ ] because
at that point
i'm in the [ __ ]
there is no chance of a second [ __ ]
if you're crying
mid stream
i don't need a second i i'm a nervous
guy i just need i didn't do the same
quantity
i like it better anyway
i just like numbers on the belt so now
now your best friend's going to ask your
sister how it went
it got kind of weird
he started weeping at like a deep
emotional
my mother died crying
and then he tried to play it off like it
was because i was so hot or something
but it was really obvious to see right
through me that he was going through
something
i think he was thinking of you finish
but it
i was know
would you rather live your life as as is
or be a billionaire but you have to blow
a dude every day
[ __ ] you guys how are things going right
now
they're not going good whatever every
day
he's coming up he's gone for a rough
couple days
the guy just got caught whacking it
he got caught jerking off bro a
billionaire lifestyle is like the dopest
thing that you can do in life yeah but
you have every day
okay but the all right the first day
sucks yeah first week first no every day
but then no no
by 803 you're done and then i got good
to live my billionaire life this is an
important part of the question is it the
same dude every day
yeah the way i'm envisioning it or is it
different he's the billionaire it's like
elon musk you're blowing him and then
you get to go out in life and like live
his money i don't know why is the guy
you're blowing attracted to you
yeah or is he just treating you like a
[ __ ] got questions
by the back of my face yeah okay cuz i
don't want to blow a straight guy every
day
like i want to just get down there and
do it just give it up it's over
then i could like you wanted to make
this depends um yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i want to then every day i can learn
what makes him come fast
he likes a little bit
then i just do that and i can just boom
watching this like male confidence is
such a thing like you're like i'll learn
how to suck the best dick in like three
weeks or something
for 20 years bro
you know they don't have the same
artistic appreciation for it
and true that's true
we know exactly what we want to just do
that to the guy yeah like
you know you i would knock your [ __ ]
socks off this is a horrible battle
i'd be okay killing myself if it's not
going well but i can't suck a dick every
day
so that's the other side if it's suicide
or suck the dick every day you're taking
suicide you take taking suicide in a
cool ass way that's
cool you would take suicide i'm too lazy
dude i barely like eating [ __ ] and i
like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's what i was gonna say it's like
isn't the it's the worst feeling when
you when you start eating [ __ ] well
with a person
you know you figure out what they're
they need
and then you switch people
and none of your [ __ ] works
on the same move and they're just like
y'all
it's like if all of a sudden they like
changed how high the hoop is and why
they poured it
like this is a different game
i swear to god i was nice
it's a nightmare i was an all-star last
week
like the dixie up down up that you know
relatively the same thing i've done
certain things that make a girl scream
and then done that same thing to another
girl and they're like
no they're literally like this that
would be fine
which is like what are you doing
you know like a like
but [ __ ] that though dad watching you
build a chair
i remember the first time i ever
experienced it i was like i was like 21
or something and i was i went to the new
chicken i was eating a [ __ ] the same
way i ate the other chicks [ __ ] and i
was like come for me and she giggled
with this
i got hit with something like that one
time i i like uh i got back together
with an ex and i was [ __ ] her and i
was like you missed this dick and she
goes i guess
it was
relatively small i suppose
i
with the boys taylor lawn uh it was he
dated this girl in in college and one of
his football teammates
he was like oh like you know rebecca i
had that girl taking out my trash
i was like
a girl he was dating someone said that
to him yes and it was a teammate who was
uh
better equipped than he was
i heard one of those same things was
like she washed my clothes and that's
like another right like do my chores oh
and uh and he probably the next day he
was probably like you mind taking out
the trash
you never think of the treasure me
no i'm just saying you're over there can
you get it
would you rather sit down with your
parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've ever had or sit by yourself and
watch a sex tape of the night that they
conceived you i'd watch every sex tape
because it's a 50 50 my
mom would be miserable my dad be like my
[ __ ] like i love it i'm loving what
you're up to right now
like that's where i get it from yeah
yeah yeah he's like boy after my whole
heart
and also like this
watching your every sexual encounter at
least you're getting variety
yeah you know it's a new thing you don't
know what's coming every night you're
like
but which one's this
oh my god i was blacked out what i'd
watch yeah but you'd settle in
like like the blowing a dude every day
yeah yeah it's just like get your
popcorn tonight i'm 69.
you have to do this yeah and watching
your dad cream pie your mind is going to
be a million times worse
like i'll take the discomfort that they
get from seeing that than the discomfort
i get from that being burned into my
brain like plus the footage for us is
going to be so much clearer
you want the vr headset tonight
all right this is a good one knowing
where you guys both fall on second day
would you rather suck one dick for fifty
thousand dollars or uh get a thousand
dollars for every dick you suck
um
damn i mean the question really is can
you suck 51 dicks yeah yeah
it's worth a thousand dollars and the
answer is yes i can yeah yeah it depends
right now in my life i'm i'm taking the
one dick yeah but
give me
one or two more years for this to not
work out and uh
i got a new hobby like
you're thinking about that like any time
you are like [ __ ] i can't make rent this
month like come on over here
yeah
yeah boom done
i want a ps5
yeah
and yeah it's like i don't know you'd
get savvy at finding the right dick to
suck yeah
well like a guy like walking around the
train station looking for a drug dealer
i go straight trans
is
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
would you rather know the lyrics to
every song ever
or get five thousand dollars
i'd rather know the lyrics every song
ever
five thousand dollars what are you gonna
do with the lyrics every song ever i
think it's kind of cool all the words i
just say dude
karaoke and [ __ ] yeah dude you [ __ ]
get laid i knew that was gonna be a
reason folks get laid in a cra like dude
if i knew lyrics to every song ever
anytime someone said something i'd be
like i got a great lyric that actually
kind of
it's almost a conversation piece yeah
yeah yeah
you know what that's great [ __ ] out like
when we like as a blogger when we would
like write a a
blog and you slide in like a good lyric
that pertains to what you know what i
mean it's like a punch line it's like
yeah that's a great call actually any
relationship fight you'd ever get in
you'd have the perfect line
whatever they're saying this is like
joni mitchell's yeah
my channel nothing lasts forever
see you think in the future i go for the
right now 5000 give me it i need it but
yeah you're right you're right also
could dig for 550.
[Laughter]
but then you got to start thinking about
like a 401 k
what about when you're 80.
is there any athlete you would be okay
with uh your girlfriend [ __ ] joella b
i mean i get why being a philly guy but
that's also the last guy i want running
up in my girl yes that's that's
yeah i'd go i'd go i'd go to someone old
school like an arnold palmer or
something
[Laughter]
you know because they'd come back from
that you'd be like what was it like
i'd say the same thing about joelle
tell me everything
i really look like no because he's
younger than you
he's got a better life than you
whatever man
he's the process what if he's exactly
and i trust it yeah but she could be
like i don't know i gave him everything
i had
and i'd be like thank you and he wanted
none of it
and then you'd start going like hmm
maybe i shouldn't be with you
dude like probably be like you should do
a movie yeah two more isn't that isn't
that a movie and decent proposal or
something yeah
would you rather bang a bunch of models
but nobody knows or not actually [ __ ]
them but have everyone think that you
did
i think this is an easy answer i think
there's an adult answer and a child
answer yeah i think look uh
if everyone actually thinks that you
[ __ ] those models then you can [ __ ]
everybody else yes
[ __ ] be getting [ __ ] yeah
as they said in the bible
though like everyone thinks that you
[ __ ] models you are like dicaprio you're
the man you're celebrating
no no i'd rather not [ __ ] i'd rather
have girls
that think they're models
there's a much hotter class of women in
my mind
girls who think they're models yes who
want to be a model but they still have
dreams they just live no no it's just
like like they think their body is
flawed
but it's perfect you know
you know what i'm saying you're saying
you like girls who lack something models
are thin in a way that i find disgusting
regular women try to get as hot as
models and they don't think that they've
gotten to that place they are actually
hotter yeah my mind damn that's deep
down you know
so i'm like you know yeah they're
shooting for the moon and they're
landing amongst the stuff
that is uh
that's philosophical now
would you blow yourself up
[Laughter]
if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself would you do it what if
everybody knew you did
uh
look if you if you could you would yeah
i like man to say you're doing it in the
bathroom
[Laughter]
jerking off in the shower
dude if it was possible for people to do
it it would be as common as jerking off
dude problem is if you alone can do it
and everybody knows that might get a
little weird i think
don't get me wrong but you'd be known as
the guy who it's not like you walk
around oh that's the guy who tugs on his
own dick because we all do it yeah if
nobody did though and somehow people
knew they'd be like oh that guy rubs his
own dick like comes all over his own
hand and [ __ ] that would be weird right
yeah
especially get getting caught sucking
your own you're all folded up like a
pretzel you're like
i was just
i was just eating nachos no you can't
wipe your mouth you got to be like chris
rock after the slap yeah
what are you up to
i think the real question is do you come
in your own mouth yes that is the
million dollar question yeah yeah
because you don't want to you don't want
to like and then do you do that hot
thing where they kind of suck no balling
a little bit
swallow and then like go back here
if you don't come in your own mouth or
at least like right before you come
you're never going to finish you're
going to have to stop too soon so you're
going to be sucking your own dick
forever forever yeah yeah
yes so it's uh yeah let's see here's the
thing so you get caught and you yourself
when you
yeah so
but also when you come you have that
you know moment of clarity where you're
the last thing you're thinking about is
sex now yeah do you want the pleasure of
coming in a mouth but then
instantaneously have like oh my god my
dick's in my mouth
or you know what i mean or do you want
to ruin the orgasm but you don't have
the feeling of this dick in my mouth
who's coming in my mouth i think i think
look i think there'd be some serious i
can't believe hannah's in the room she's
the new girl
she's on the computer she's reading
about like christian camps
finding a new job
indeed
can i where can i walk dogs in nashville
yeah yeah i think i think i think i
would come in my own mouth for sure
and on that note
that's answer the internet boys
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon